you guys aren't gonna make us wait too
much longer what can you tell us though
to hold us over till the premiere cuz
it's been long enough
no it's been long enough cuz we've just
been making the best season ever ever
ever ever ever right yes the best season
ever
it's buzz yeah well you know that you
were missed and welcome back to the
Emmys tonight in grand style
congratulations on winning Best Drama
series so happy to be with these guys
it's just like a testament to have you
shot your final scenes yet and are you
happy with how things ended bad season
ever
what was it like shooting those final
scenes though and you knew it was fine
so sighs so sappy then everyone gets
ready for the emotion and everyone's
there being like oh it's gonna be the
lot how many more takes are we gonna
we're just gonna and then it kind of
wears off this is the last one this is
the last scene like or takes in you're
like okay the Momentum's drops a little
bit now to be my last day oh my finished
I mean they were like oh but you need to
pick we've got pickup of you in a
month's time and I was like I gotta do
my own doing about eight times a times
and more big you are is I haven't gotten
by like you can't say goodbye anyone
you're like hold on Duke can i yeah put
it what yeah yeah but that's I mean I
don't mind they can call me back as many
times as they want to be on it because
it was sad when they find anyway
and he seems to make it last did you say
that playing Khaleesi almost ruined your
hair what happened no well I dyed it
blonde up it's a bleach on my hair and
then when you were bleaching your hair
don't grow back so I'm like dialing this
out I'm going brown again I'm styling it
out I know there's bits there's bits
it's just I like the blonde I also like
hair you're like having it so me a
choice
[Music]